you know obviously up the score is like
you're i mean that [ __ ] is going crazy
yeah but it's time still still moving i
mean um
how did the dirk feature come to be like
like you guys have had a relationship
i'm assuming we ain't i know like no
friendship relationship type [ __ ] but i
always knew him you know he knew of me
it was just mutual respect just overall
just because being from where he from
from where i'm from you know and like
when i did the song i just heard him on
that [ __ ] we reached out and that [ __ ]
got done with like within like a week
did you have to pay him for the future
ah it was just
like wow
that's big
you know that [ __ ] was all gangster i
mean now you owe him a feature
yeah for so long
you gotta
no of course of course but it's just
off of respect like when you see a [ __ ]
that big like that you know what i'm
saying like
you can run with some free [ __ ] you feel
me but it's like when you want the
business to be done and to be done
properly and i want to profit off of
this song you want to maximize the
potential of the song everyone's got to
get situated so it's like man listen
[ __ ] that huh like yeah huh you get what
i'm saying but it wouldn't know like i
didn't have to pay for that verse at all
but as [ __ ] got done because of the
business part and just out of respect
like and there ain't no food like i
don't think about just getting no more
[ __ ] song and you put it on itunes
and you maximizing out on this [ __ ] you
getting booked for shows
off this [ __ ] and [ __ ] just ain't
getting nothing you know you either one
or two things gonna happen that's that
song ain't gonna get supported or you
feel me you gotta bless that [ __ ] if
you know you see him
i mean he blessed you back i saw you uh
you were on the i don't know how many
dates of the little baby dirk tour
you're on but i know you're on in
phoenix right for sure yeah yeah what
what i mean that's a big that's a big
thing yeah i ain't doing it every day
because i'm you know i got so many shows
booked up but like if i if if this [ __ ]
would have came about before like all
them shows i could have did every single
date with you're doing spot dates on the
tour exactly the dates i'm available i
ain't gonna just cancel all of my
[ __ ] shows and steal my money yeah
that ain't a tour like i'm i ain't
getting paid
for that like i wouldn't even want no
that's opportunity it's opportunity i
ain't a fool you know what i'm saying i
wouldn't even go in those situations
like that ask for that [ __ ]
right right
yeah what i mean that [ __ ] just sound
dumb for sure i feel me so but at the
same time i got to feed my family mm-hmm
making 40 000 so i gotta get my you
heard